depuis le mois de mars 2019 le morceau
du pipeline d'ile-de-france à l'origine
de la fuite d'hydrocarbures a été
remplacé 60 autres défauts identifiés
par un robot racleurs ont aussi été
corrigés avant une remise en
fonctionnement cet été le pas et
fonctionne à une pression opératoire
inférieure à celle qu'on avait avant la
fuite par arrêté préfectoral
vous voyez un espèce de tapis c'est un
géotextile de protection qui qui sert à
faire la jonction là la différence
physique entre les terres et la partie
technique du pape
au total cinquante mille mètres cubes de
terres polluées ont été retirés une
nouvelle phase vient de débuter sur le
chantier l'apport de nouvelles terres
sur les zones touchées par la fuite
nous sommes donc en train de rapporter
de la terre minérale autour du
'pipeline' pour le protéger et dans une
deuxième phase on en rapportera de la
terminer râle et de la terre végétale
pour permettre aux agriculteurs de
reprendre leurs pratiques culturales
classique on creuse plus ou moins
profondément en fonction de la qualité
des sols que l'on prélève et que l'on
fait analyser dans des laboratoires pour
savoir si on a des hydrocarbures ou plus
d'hydrocarbures des contrôles de
pollution sont encore effectuées
notamment à travers ses puits jaune pour
contrôler les nappes phréatiques pour ce
bois touchés par le déversement
d'hydrocarbures le nettoyage a été
effectué il ne sera pas abattu
notre analyse a montré qu'on pouvait
laisser des arbres en l'espèce recouvrir
d'humus le sol du petit bois et laissé
des traces d'hydrocarbures qui restait
être
des intérêts en fait par la nature elle
même et ainsi baisser les arbres
centenaires
le protocole de total a été envoyée à la
préfecture il doit recevoir la
validation de l'état la fin du chantier
prévue pour octobre 2020